i'm duke diver resident manager of this
resort community
[Applause]
[Music]
new resident I think you're gonna be
very impressed with what we have here
boo tango Tai Chi people just seem so
happy here Duke the Duke the Duke he's a
resident champion of everything around
here who is at my parking spot
it's mr. divers spot mr. diver make me
wear those clothes there's new food on
the buffet what 20 minutes he's got him
lined up for a freeway full wave
everybody's counting this weight from
Leo I'm a citizen of the world military
ex-military
I had a Warner cousin we play for real
money here some big brass huevos he's
got city wolf developed free just to
piss me off
no that was just a happy byproduct you
and I just getting started this was not
an accident
we're out of here why would I do that
for you I got a big secret you know I
was the star witness against the mob and
you went into witness protection
you can't even do that right babe I
think you and I could become cherished
friends leo
you need therapy I wanted you to lift me
like that do you men hear yourselves
this is really stuck on probably just a
gasoline leak
so it's an electric car you've changed
your foods and this with this I don't
think so
[Music]
you